What the heck is Consensus Reality?
And is it really the answer to everything?
You may have seen us mention the subject before.
Consensus Reality after all, is what the SCP
Foundation is trying to preserve in the face
of ever-increasing anomalous activity: A kind
of “truth” or “normalcy” that all
of us can agree on.
Pick ten people at random and ask them: “What
color is the sky?”, “What gaseous element
is produced by trees?”, “Has every US
President since Washington secretly been an
alien reptile in disguise?”
The answers will, or at least should be “Blue”,
“Oxygen”, and “No.”
This is Consensus Reality.
But…
No.
Not really.
Yes, in a more casual sense, “the state
of reality to which we all agree” could
be a viable definition of the term “Consensus
Reality”, but you likely don’t remember
being called upon for a vote along with the
rest of humanity on what is and isn’t quote
unquote normal.
That’s because Consensus Reality isn’t
the consensus of everyone, it’s the consensus
of the most powerful beings alive: The O5
Council.
In this instance, SCP-001 is the ever-updating
document that records exactly what “Normal”
is.
But perhaps even more important, is that anything
that exists outside the Council’s most recent
definition of “Normal” is targeted for
containment.
While, at face value, it seems less flashy
than something like The Gate Guardian, or
the terrifying Scarlet King, or the insane
twists and turns of the Ouroboros Cycle, the
document defining Consensus Reality - despite
being the only thing on the database to be
given the classification “Non-Anomalous”
- is about as, ahem, Foundational, as Foundation
documents get.
Literally everything currently in containment
is there because this document deems it so.
It’s the SCP Foundation’s Ten Commandments
of Containment, and Thou Shalt Contain.
If this document was ever leaked, it could
lead to a complete Broken Masquerade scenario,
where the anomalous cat is let fully out of
the bag.
Only the O5 Council has access to the document,
and it’s only through consensus that additions,
alterations, or removals can be made.
Naturally, it’s a document that’s in extremely
high demand among the anomalous community,
because it answers the big question that every
anomalous individual has:
“If I’m not even dangerous, if I’ve
committed no crime that would necessitate
the locking up of a non-anomalous human, why
am I still being contained?”
And don’t worry.
Today, we’re going to answer that question.
Or rather, the O5 Council will.
But let’s return to the Council themselves.
We’ve covered them and their many interpretations
before: From them being a group of fantastical,
immortal demigods, to being a frightening
hive mind, to being a shadowy
faction of mysterious,
emotionless bureaucrats, constantly conniving
and undermining each other to gain just that
little bit more power.
But what’s more frightening: The keys to
normality being in the hands of these larger
than life, fantastical figures, or in the
hands of human beings, just as fallible and
afraid as the rest of us - with only the knowledge
of the strange things going on behind the
curtain to protect them from the truly unknowable?
The O5 Council holds meetings with some regularity
where they ask themselves and each other whether
any new developments in the wider world require
changes to the New Normal.
It is up to the O5 Council
to define the difference
between universal laws - gravitation, physical
forces, and basic chemistry, biology, sociology,
psychology, technology, and philosophy - and
the kind of crackpot theories being spouted
by people on street corners carrying “The
End is Nigh” signs.
Some of their decisions are quite simple:
Can a new development be explained by the
laws of an existing, non-anomalous framework?
If so, the rules need not be changed.
The current paradigm of our understanding
can rest neatly in place.
But other decisions fall into a grey area.
In order to illustrate this, we’re going
to do something unprecedented.
We’re going to go into the actual boardroom
of the O5 Council, and see exactly what decisions
they made about our Consensus Reality, the
one that you and I are living in right now.
We’re going to look at three different meetings,
one from 1932, another from 1945, and a final
example from as recently as 2014.
So what really goes on in the discussions
that define what we all would consider normal?
The 1932 discussion was spurred on by a strange
development happening in the United Kingdom.
New forms of Occult-adjacent Witchcraft and
spiritualism were beginning to take off, descended
largely from traditional Pagan and Wicca beliefs.
The fact that some of these believers were
actually attempting spells was enough to catch
the Foundation’s all-seeing eye, and the
matter was discussed by the O5 Council.
O5-3 said, “Why are we even covering this?
There are traditional beliefs in cultures
throughout history that we do not consider
anomalous.
We must not use our position to threaten the
right of humanity to believe.”
With a stern look, O5-7 replied, “Except
this does not extend from traditional practices.
This new "witch-craft" is a modern invention,
developed through a scholarly rereading of
practices as an alternative to Christianity.
It is not a continuation, and practitioners
are attempting spell-casting.”
O5-5 chimed in with, “Soon you'll say Aleister
Crowley has something to do with it.
The document is clear: theurgy is anomalous,
religion and spirituality are not.
Show me proof that they are casting spells
that cannot be explained under rigorous testing,
and I will personally see to containing those
spells myself.
Until then, no, just as Thelema is allowed,
so shall this witch-craft.
For God's sake, we'll allow Satanism as long
as they aren't channeling demonic energies.”
O5-1, the most senior member of the Council,
nodded and said, “Agreed.
Furthermore, we will need all the faith we
can muster against the theurgic traditions.
We never know when a new faith will assist
in our cause.”
No updates to consensus reality were made.
In 1945, an event of far greater magnitude
took place: The use of terrifying, new weapons
by the US Military in Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
that resulted in the deaths of over 200,000
people.
The Council converged to discuss the earth
shattering event, and what their reaction
to it should be.
Shaking, O5-2 said, “Thank you for responding
to my emergency call.
Trinity has happened.
I can barely comprehend what I saw.
It was like the sun rising from the desert
sand, a dawn of destruction and fire that
lasted for miles around.
I cannot believe that such an explosion could
ever be seen as possible.
Tales and prior evidence of the summoning
of gods have had less impact.
I tremble with fear about the possibility
of people wielding this kind of power, the
ability to level a city with the flick of
a switch.”
O5-4 replied, “Weren't the Germans and Russians
also developing this technology?
We are at war, and this sort of escalation
happens.”
O5-5 said, “May I remind my esteemed colleague
that we are not at war?
The United States, Japan, they are at war.
We are not nations.
No, the question stands: is this anomalous?
Do the physical effects
follow from the mathematical
concepts?”
O5-7 replied, “They do follow.
Scientific testing was completed each and
every step of the way to reach this point.
I do not believe this is anomalous, no matter
how frightening the repercussions are.”
O5-2, still understandably worked up, said,
“What, you're just going to let people hold
onto the keys to their own destruction?
We have fought tooth and nail to keep such
capabilities out of the reach of man, and
you're now saying we should abandon our purpose?”
O5-5 said, “We do not prevent destruction.
We sequester the anomalous.
And as long as we agree that the test was
arrived at through diligent scientific process,
available to anyone -”
But 05-2 simply wasn’t having it.
He shot back with, “Available to anyone?
Listen to yourself, man!
Can you imagine a future where any two-bit
dictator chooses to unleash the fire of a
thousand suns wherever he wishes?
Maybe the problem isn't with the equations.
Maybe the whole of nuclear physics is anomalous
itself.”
O5-1 once again brought his own level-headed
perspective to the table: “Enrico Fermi
has already received a Nobel Prize for his
work on transuranic elements and radioactivity.
We can't just secure nuclear physics from
the world.
Radioactivity is everywhere, and we end up
causing more contradictions when we try to
send ourselves back to the Dark Ages.
Try explaining chemistry without referring
to covalent bonds.
Try explaining biology.
Nuclear physics is here to stay, and we had
better get used to the consequences of this,
no matter how terrifying this will be for
the planet and for humanity.”
With a rattling sigh, O5-2 once again took
a seat, murmuring, “May God have mercy on
our souls…”
In the aftermath of this debate, the document
on Consensus Reality was altered to reflect
these new developments in nuclear physics,
as frightening as they were.
I think we can all form a consensus on the
fact that one-off murder is a less depressing
subject than mass murder.
And it was a single murder that led to the
O5 Council discussing the concept of Worms
That Walk in 2014.
O5-6 came to the table with, “For those
unfamiliar with the topic, the "worm that
walks" is a trope in which a character is
actually a writhing hive-mind of worms generally
held together as a single mass.
We are not here to discuss this trope.
Instead, we are here to discuss the recent
conspiracy that has arisen from it.
The conspiracy is the idea
that certain individuals
are actually worms that walk, and not humans.”
When asked if this conspiracy had any merit
to it, O5-6 replied, “No.
Individual conspiracy believers are divided
themselves on who is a worm that walks and
who isn't, and all evidence indicates that
there aren't actual worms that walk in the
general populace.
It pretty clearly falls under irreproducible
conspiracy theories.
I believe there's nothing we need to do or
change in SCP-001.”
Another member of the Council wasn’t so
sure that these results were irreproducible,
saying, “On 12/11/2013, a believer in the
conspiracy from Decatur, Alabama, killed his
neighbor under the belief that the neighbor
was a worm that walks.
The killer then took a video of his deceased
neighbor and uploaded it to YouTube, claiming
it was proof of the conspiracy, and that the
corpse was dissolving into individual worms
before his very eyes.
He said that he was going to take a sample.
The video was very quickly blocked and removed,
and everyone who has viewed the video agrees
that the subject is unmoving and does not
dissolve into worms.
The killer turned himself in to the police
while clutching a jar of Tubifex worms and
the neighbor sent to the Morgan County morgue.
Autopsy confirmed that the decedent was missing
a thumb postmortem and killed by gunshot to
the chest - which, if he were a worm that
walks, would be survivable.”
When questioned whether these were just the
actions of a single insane man, the Council
member continued “The one item of interest
was that after the autopsy, the assistant
coroner oversaw the return of the body to
the next of kin.
The assistant coroner was also a conspiracy
believer, and despite not having had any prior
contact to the parties involved, screamed
in disgust upon entering the examination room,
grabbing a mop and complaining about all the
worms everywhere.
No one else noticed any
signs of worm infestation.”
It was further discussed that D-Classes who
were shown the body didn’t see it as anything
other than a corpse.
However, after being told about the Worm that
Walks trope, several of them saw it as a writhing
mass of worms.
Some believed that this could be a memetic
side effect of actually encountering a living
worm that walks, and updates were made to
the document to reference the possible existence
of perceptual mnestic worm triggers.
So now you know what the O5 Council is up
to when not playing office golf or plotting
each other’s downfalls: They’re having
discussions about witchcraft, war crimes,
and walking worms.
You’re probably feeling a pang of curiosity
about the actual SCP-001 document, especially
if you’re an understandably vindictive anomalous
individual wondering why the Foundation is
carting you off to paranormal Gitmo for the
simple crime of existing.
And if you look for the true document, and
you manage to survive the memetic kill agents
put in place to stop you, then what you’ll
actually find is even stranger: A letter,
to you, from O5-5, explaining exactly what’s
happening to you.
The letter reads:
“Hello.
I'm afraid you won't find SCP-001 here.
It's stored in a far more unreachable location
than this.
I'm sure you were hoping you could get in,
edit it in a couple places here and there,
and voilà, you're no longer anomalous, you're
free to go, the Foundation will harass you
no longer.
Of course, it can't be that easy.
But I am going to help you.
You deserve this much.
I'm going to tell you why.
Why the Foundation targets you.
Why we deem you something
to contain, to persecute.
After all, there are far worse evils in the
world.
We kept our record of nuclear weapons above
as an example.
There are numerous genocides throughout history.
The death toll from just the flu alone is
far greater that the potential damage for
thousands of the people and objects we contain,
and yet we dedicate ourselves to branding
you anomalous.
Something not normal.
Something inherently wrong.
Something that cannot be allowed its peace.
Why?
I'm not going to patronize you and say there's
nothing I can do.
I am only one voice on the Council, and I
can't change things on my own, that's true,
but the decisions I make, and the way I let
myself view your circumstance are a direct
cause of people seeing fit to throw you into
a box.
Even if I can't change the document, I could
remain one more advocate for your normalcy.
After all, humanity has believed in ghosts
and spirits for thousands of years.
We all believe in the monster under our beds
when we're children.
These phenomena are very real, and very much
a part of the way the world works.
Why can't we just declare them normal?
Why won't I free you from your torment?
It's because we aren't only here to secure,
contain, and protect the world.
We're here to secure, contain, and protect
you.
The defining feature of the anomalous is that
it cannot be explained through simple scientific
testing.
This makes you and your nature different.
Unique, even.
And that scarcity makes it valuable.
But that doesn't mean that your value is something
everyone can appreciate.
Sometimes, it can only be appreciated by those
who would use it against you.
That scarcity is also the tool by which a
monster can exploit you.
Others aren't familiar with your anomaly,
and won't respond to descriptions of it as
real.
This gives opportunity to nefarious individuals
to exploit that lack of knowledge and use
you as an eldritch pawn to their pleasure.
They can isolate you, consume you, make your
anomaly their lever to destroy, slake a sadistic
thirst with your existence.
I'm sure you've seen it happen.
Someone is different.
Their desires, needs, their reality forces
them to be ostracized by the world at large.
They're left alone.
Probably not friendless, but sidelined, starved
for connection.
That's when someone swoops
in, promising greatness,
but only offering that connection you crave
through consumption of you, destruction of
your world, perversion of your reality.
You fight back, try to tell someone of your
plight, but others respond, "Oh, that can't
be happening.
That's not real.
You must be mistaken."
You are alone in your anomaly, and left to
suffer.
We can't let that happen.
Yes, go ahead, point out that we're isolating
you at least as well, slowly consuming you
and your existence just as surely as some
abuser might wish to burn you up.
Call us monsters.
It's okay.
But keep in mind that even in our pursuit
of you, our coverup, our incarceration of
you, we still want to make sure that you continue
to exist, that you aren't removed entirely
from this world.
You have every right to exist.
You have every right to be as different as
you are.
You, the monsters out there, the monsters
in here, you are all just as real as we are.
Just as real as the teeming,
irrational, self-destructive
humanity that remains ignorant to your plight.
And the conclusion that we are all, in the
end, the same stuff, I hope you can find comfort
in it.
Yes, you are a monster.
But, whether we are deemed anomalous or not,
so is every last one of us.
And that means you deserve your existence.
We secure you.
We contain you.
We protect you.
And even if you still don't get why I'm doing
this, please understand that I still love
you.”
Now go check out “Children of SCP-001 The
Scarlet King - Is SCP-999 Really His Son?”
and “SCP-001 Ouroboros Cycle - The Full
Story Compilation” for more perspectives
on the ever-elusive SCP-001!